beep in a Slovak forest awaits the leshy
towering above the trees and eagerly
looking for weary and lost travelers to
have its fun with Silesia quite an
interesting set of spirits that are
depicted in numerous ways throughout
slavic mythology now some of you who
have followed the channel for a while
will know that i have previously
discussed alesci in a video going over
some of the strange slavic creatures but
i've always been a big fan of ents and
tree people so they less she get their
own video in terms of what unless she
actually looks like they normally
resemble a large human being with long
green hair and beards made from living
vines or grass it's believed that will
unless she's at the center of the forest
they appear as a giant tree as their
long limbs resemble tree branches and
their grassy facial hair means they can
easily bend into the trees and greenery
around them as they travel away from the
center and closer to the outskirts of
the forest they shrink in size until
they are so small they can be mistaken
for leaves and shrubbery they do however
have a distinct pair of bright green
eyes which is probably the easiest way
to distinguish between Alesi in a
regular tree there are a few different
types of Leschi
with one of the most common being the
trickster Leschi these are not really
described as being evil but at times
they can take their jokes and their
pranks a little too far and they often
take pleasure and interacting with
travelers misleading them and confusing
them causing them to wander deeper into
the forest
unless you do eventually grow bored
allowing these poor victims to leave
giving travelers a fright is another
thing that they've been known to enjoy
they do despite imitating the voices of
people that wander into the forest
making it sound like these voices are in
their own head oddly enough there are
people who have claimed to have had
friends and family members who have been
tickled to death by Leschi they're all
ashy who were far more protective than
Trix the like and these service
protectors of the forest and the
wildlife inside they said to have a
noticeable bond with wolves and bears
and this is surely aided by the fact
that they can transform into any plant
or animals that can be found in the
forest if there is more than one less
you didn't habits of forest then they
generally have a fight for the
territorial rights of that forest fallen
trees were sometimes described as being
the aftermath of one of these struggles
despite not having a great relationship
with other male leshy
they still live with their wives in
their children so if you thought that
one issue was bad then I imagine an
encounter when entire family of tricks
the spirits would be less and enjoyable
so if you are being pursued by a family
of Leschi then how exactly does one
escape the sign of a cross was believed
to be the most straightforward option
but some believe that if you sat under
it
and put your clothes on backwards then
you would gain the respect of the Leschi
and they would let you go I have no idea
why this would actually work but maybe
some less you just enjoyed watching
humans make a fool of themselves now if
you do somehow manage to befriend Allah
she it is said that they will share with
you the secrets of the forest and their
magic it became a pretty common practice
amongst farmers and shepherds to make
packs of the leshy in the hopes that
they would protect their crops in their
livestock the leshy are not one of those
creatures where you never really know
what exactly you're going to encounter
be it a trickster a protector or even a
family of killer trees your guess is as
good as mine as I mentioned earlier I've
always been a big fan of ensign tree
beard in particular
ever since I've read and watched Lord of
the Rings and I'd like to think that
unless she could have in fact been one
of tokens many influences the depictions
and even the names of less she naturally
differ depending on which Slavic country
that you're from so if you're free to
show any differences and similarities
you may have encountered with me in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained